hi i'm james murphy have you ever come
across an error when trying to import a
module
in this case it's telling me that i
can't import my function a from a
partially initialized module a
scrolling over it tells me that the most
likely cause is a circular import
in this video we'll go over how these
circular imports commonly arise and what
are the main ways to fix them
here's the simplest and most common way
that this kind of import cycle can
happen
at runtime main tried to import
something from a so it starts
initializing a it starts running the
code from a
but the first line in a is to import
something from module b
so it stops initializing a because b has
to be initialized first and then it hops
over to b and starts running that code
instead
but then the first line in b is that it
needs something from a so it stops
running b and goes over to a
and it would like to just start
initializing a but it realizes that a is
already in the process of initialization
so that's where the error occurs
we can actually see this chain of events
unfold in the traceback here we see in
main it tries to import function a for
module a which triggered the import of
function b for module b which then
triggered the import of function a again
from module a which is then where the
final error occurred
the way that things are written right
now we have an import time cycle between
the modules a and b
but if you actually look at the names
that we imported we don't actually use
them at import time we use them when
this function a or when this function b2
are called since we're not actually
calling these functions at import time
there's no true cyclic dependency which
means we can get rid of this import
cycle
there are three common ways to resolve
this issue the first one is to take your
import and put it inside of the function
in python imports can happen at any time
including when a function is called so
if this is the only place that you need
this function b1 then it could be okay
to just do the import right here
this could actually be even more
efficient because if you never call the
function a then it may be that you never
even have to import b at all
but let's say that you have a bunch of
different functions in a and a lot of
different ones use this function b1
in that case the better solution would
be to just import the module b directly
and then in the functions where you use
it use the longer name module b
dot function b1
go ahead and do this conversion for all
modules involved in the cycle
let's see how this resolves the import
cycle at runtime
first our main function tries to import
something from a causing a to start
running
in a we get to the import module b which
triggers b to start running
in b when we get to the import module a
because the a module has already started
initializing this module object
technically exists
since it exists it doesn't start running
this again it just says okay that exists
so the b module will just continue on
finish its import and then after that
import is done the a module will finish
importing
the third and final common way to get
rid of this import cycle is to just
merge the two modules together no
imports no import cycles however if you
had two or maybe even more modules in
the first place you probably had them
for a reason so i'm not just going to
recommend that you take all of your
modules and merge them into one that
would be kind of silly so for that
reason you should probably prefer using
one of the first two methods
let's take a look at another example the
next most common kind of import cycle
that you'll run into is due to using
type hints
this example is not like the previous
one because type annotations are defined
on a function definition or class
definition when the function is defined
or when the class is defined not when
it's run
but if you think about it the most
common use case of type hinting is not
even at runtime it's for static type
analyzers like my pie
if all we care about is static analysis
then we don't even need to do the import
at runtime
the typing module provides this variable
type checking which is just false at
runtime so if you put all the imports
that you just need for the purpose of
type checking in one of these if type
checking checks then none of those will
actually happen at runtime completely
avoiding the import loop
but now if you import this function
you're going to get a name error because
this name b hasn't been imported
to fix this go ahead and add this from
future import annotations what this
actually does is it changes the way that
annotations work instead of evaluating b
as a name all annotations are converted
to strings
so now you don't get an error at runtime
here because even though the name b
isn't imported the string b certainly
exists
you should be aware though that whenever
you do one of these from future imports
it's not necessarily guaranteed behavior
forever
right now this causes your annotations
to be handled as strings but there's
actually a competing proposal to make
them just be evaluated lazily so they're
just not evaluated at all unless you try
to look at them
unless you're actually inspecting your
type hints at runtime this probably
won't make any difference for your code
base but you should still be aware
an alternative solution is to again just
use import modules instead of from
module imports
you will still need the from future
import annotations and the downside to
this approach is that your type hints
look kind of you know not as nice
now let's take a look at a very tricky
cycle that some larger projects will run
into this is what i call the sub package
init cycle
the actual structure of the package is
important for this example so let's go
over it
first i have a main script it's outside
of the package and just tries to import
some class from some module in the
package and do whatever very similar to
the previous case
now this package my package contains two
sub packages sub package a and sub
package b
sub package a contains two modules
module a and c and sub package b
contains the module b
for whatever reason let's assume that
module a needs something out of module b
here's module b which we also assume
depends on module c
but looking at module c module c doesn't
depend on anything so there's no actual
cycle here a depends on b and b depends
on c c doesn't depend on anything
nevertheless when we try to run it we do
get an import cycle so what happened
the problem here is not with any of the
modules a b or c the actual issue is in
these sub package init files
our subpackage init files here are
re-exporting some names in this case
classes from some of the modules inside
of them
doing this is pretty common in python
projects because it allows you to have
shorter import syntax here i can just
have a client say from my package dot
sub package a in port a instead of the
longer from my package sub package a
module a import a
the problem with doing this is that
every module in a sub package depends on
the init of the sub package so if the
init of the sub package depends on all
of the modules in the sub package then
you've kind of made a fake dependency of
every module in the sub package on every
other module in the sub package
that means even though c has no imports
at all c now automatically also depends
on a because it depends on the init
let's see this by starting in main and
following the trace back
main tries to import something from
module b
so to import something from module b we
first have to run the sub package init
all sub package b does is import from
module b so we start importing module b
module b wants to import something from
module c so first we have to initialize
sub package a that contains module c
but sub package a imports from module a
and module a imports from module b so
now we have a cycle because we haven't
finished initializing
way to get rid of this cycle is to just
make all of your init files blank
if you still want to give your users a
short way to import names rather than
importing directly from the modules you
can define what i call an interface
package
this is a package that has no extra
modules just its init
inside the init you put all the things
that you wanted to import from your
other sub package
now your users can import from the
interface instead of reaching directly
into the modules and there's still no
import cycles
depending on your use case you might
give the interface a separate name but a
lot of packages just make the true
package that has all the modules in it
underscore whatever and then make the
interface name just the whatever
so what was interface a just became sub
package a and what was sub package a
became underscore sub package a
finally let's take a look at the worst
example we're back to just a flat
directory structure we just have two
modules but in this case both of the
modules depend on each other a depends
on b b depends on a and they actually
use those dependencies at import time
this is the worst and most difficult
case primarily because this often
involves an architectural error
if you're actually using something from
b and a then that thing needs to be
defined so b needs to be initialized
before a but if you're also using
something from a and b
then a needs to be initialized before b
well which one is it does b need to come
before a or does a need to come before b
in my experience if your modules are
that intertwined that they need each
other both at import time that kind of
suggests to me that they should probably
be the same module merging them together
is your best bet
however the most common case that i see
this come up is when someone tries to
mix library code with script code
most commonly these import time
dependencies are not really necessary
and you should just pull them out into a
script and leave the remaining library
code alone
if you can't strip out these import time
dependencies then i'm sorry there's not
much i can do to help you
your application needs some serious
redesigning it's going to be a mess no
matter how you do it and there's no
general advice i can give you just good
luck
as always thank you for watching thank
you to my patrons and donors for
supporting me
don't forget to subscribe comment and
slap that like button an odd number of
times see you next time